I think at one point in my career I was
addicted on jury yeah it was like a drug
because literally you bought one thing
and then it just you'd look at it for
like a couple weeks and then it gets
small you know it'd be big when you
first bought it then it gets small and
then you got to get bigger [ __ ]
[Music]
it was subject kilo yachty you know a
rocks first piece I have ever got my
imagine my CEO they bought me a baby
boat was like this but it was 3d it was
constructed so then John Tommy John he
redid it super detail I bought it with
this cube milling I paid sixty thousand
it's the first chain I'll pay for my own
money
I was excited this [ __ ] cuz it's my
first big chain I had little small
chains and I'm from there I kind of went
crazy
this is self-made me no saying can't get
the teens this was about $50,000 it's a
self-portrait you got to do a split of
the porch and so you can see how
identical this looks it has this grill
in the mouth it has this watch on the
hand and then my career braces that I'll
never take off if those are on the arm
and then this bracelet is on the other
hand with a tennis bracelet that I had I
lost it
this ring on the finger I lost that ring
too but that rings like this ring except
for all white diamonds and I had this
thread setting the rock band down horn
if you can see it's like this red with
the rubies a super dope this is folk
Simpson you know Gucci Mane he did a
Bart Simpson P so a long time ago and I
recreated it you know I'm saying hey I'm
mr. Gucci Bart was always though both
got like a little boat on the bag some
1017 Birds at the top yeah this was 100
grand and then I got this chain I hadn't
ever seen it before and you always see
diamond chains but these are different
gemstones it's just like 20 grand this
was kind of cheap at 25 maybe 30 grand
maybe that was dumb cheap then I have
daddy Jesus gaudy Christ got the gold
teeth red hair with the diamond be one
of my favorite sayings on the bag they
hate on me but they hated Jesus from the
late great soldier boy okay I got this
chain with this diamond rosary this
chain was so [ __ ] expensive it was
like 50 grand because so many little
dumb and then this was like 25 think I
pay like 70 something for these two
together
I got a QC pendant QC is delayed with
quality control that I regularly know
I'm saying
originally no everyone had just a white
one and then clay volcanic and Mahesh it
starts spinning and [ __ ] me over so
I'm back to the drawing board I'm John
and see if I can make my [ __ ] fly or
something I got this bracelet this is
the only brush that I didn't lose that
says boat boy on it it's dope right I
don't even wear it says boat boy I got
this no solid foundation piece which is
not management if you see me goes you
see me see trippy red and I'm saying we
all got we all wear this on the big old
boogers you see right did them carrots
and whatnot the chain alone this was a
50 that pay 55 grand just for this
little chain whoa I should have [ __ ]
broke off oh yeah yep I gotta get this
chain fixed again I get that change
based on glad I just raised that up I
gotta get the end of it fixed so we got
all my diamond chains not all of them
you see a lot of people wearing these
diamonds and they be wearing a fake
diamond diamond diamond chains are not
cheap I'm glad I got this segment to
talk about jury for second toast a lot
of you rappers and you see your jury and
it's a little sheisty you know I'm
saying yeah a couple of them it's just
the stuff that actually never sees the
light of day like when you go to your
toy collection you got those toys that
you never play with it just sit in the
box what we got on you know what we got
them you know just in case somebody was
curious if we got them they're got this
change icebox
I paid 140 grand for it and I love
icebox I feel like I was a little too
much you know I'm saying I was a little
too much but I did I paid 140 grand for
it
70 pointers I think and I knew I paid
much because then I got this 90 pointer
for 90 and anything I'm saying you can
go quote me I don't have a reason why
you feel me anything you want a quote
you can go ask do they let you know I
don't have a reason why
then my boy John hooked me up with these
two for 15 15 grand sake [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that was 15 we take down the
skirt then we get them mine and I pay
like 20 for this one maybe 30 longer one
of my first time in chains
that's when I realized how expensive
diamond chains wear it you know I'm
saying and then I got this one I paid I
know for a fact I paid 50 grand for this
one because as long as it's the longest
one I have and the stones are pretty big
they're like fifty pointers and then I
pay fifty five grand for this one
because I got those super big stones in
the middle really was the females chain
and didn't fit my neck I was like I have
more links to it I wanted 55 man bought
it cuz I can just custom a lot Jane I
got me it's a real lock I got the link
may I start Skepta wearing a chain like
this but it was enticed I was just very
good and it was way smaller it's like I
want that but bigger and I style so we
made it and then got this iced out boat
key attached him I made that key you
knows a notch on a flex and nothing just
how you take it off you know it's crazy
because I've worn the chain out and
forgot the key and then you stuck with
it
chain is so heavy it's like a kilo and a
half
[Music]
we got this big-ass Cuban this Cubans
almost two kilos almost I cannot wear
this chain for over ten minutes
it's so [ __ ] heavy I get some
diamonds per beginning this was 150
I wouldn't supposed to buy this man
that's how they always get me always
coming in with [ __ ]
he just had it he was the biggest one I
ever seen so I like old [ __ ]
no one has one this big so I'm gonna buy
one this big I've this chain it's like a
puffer Cuban the super dope no one has
this chain either like a lot of pre
trappers have this bracelet pressures
like 40 grams like 40 grand for my spots
but the chain know saying I got the
chain for about 75 80 grand is like 77
scented middle so I'm with or close to
80 you know how I do I'm gonna throw
close to 80 there's both nice box not
told him if I bought it but not see it
on no more rappers don't make it no more
you know I'm saying it's the closest to
the DMX chain cause I really wanted DMX
is change it's like a Cuban but it's a
little different I forgot the name of
it's like a special type of Cuban it's
super expensive because of course how I
sit out his was just like solid but it
would be like super duper duper duper
duper expensive like this specific type
of to me anyways so I just got these two
this is like a gang channel colleague
and change the 17 piece everybody in my
gang got my engineers my manager Co
security anybody I [ __ ] with if I really
[ __ ] with you you get a gang chairs 17
chains and I'm saying and which gives me
for my next they pig daddy came you know
I'm saying with the with the solitaire
in the middle this is still a gang chain
it's just a gang gang chain no I'm
saying this is a new gang chain this is
the first ones to look prototype it's
Popeye Popeye the Sailor I got a bunch
of these coming for the otter game and
then I got the Big Daddy Kane when for
myself coming of course sometimes we
like it up
I love watches I got this Patek Phillipe
rose gold you know I'm saying I had
swapped the face I got the blue face I'm
saying blue face doesn't come when the
rose well Patek it comes elsewhere so I
had it put in there first Rolex ever
bought a little country joint I got this
Jubilee two-tone except for mine's got
the big face this watch is very popular
right now it's kind of cheap it's like
29 but I got the biggest bezel and I'm
saying I got these big-ass diamonds in
the face big old boogers make you say
out you how about this watch it's just
some Rolex it's a scarred oiler with the
baguettes around inside me and my
brother offset both got this watch that
blue face anything I'm saying blue face
make it say grace you know I'm saying
you didn't you get one going I felt all
the way around
first of all X I forgot was a gift this
is Jacques Nasser I'm saying it me being
a yachty is brand-new nice and clean
solid gold just watches heavy as [ __ ]
watch like 40 grand and then I have a I
have a watch sitting on my nightstand a
row legs I'm gonna say presidential
baguettes all around it just in case you
wonder why these two were empty because
I ain't no sucker you feel me
[Music]
this AP is special edition ap this is
from the Qt second cup 2006 and if you
can get the key to the inside of that
way your little brother was just being
born JP was about 80 80 something like
85 86 granite look at that look at that
face
the Tom set when this [ __ ] is
not tonight time you're not gonna talk
about that we're not gonna talk about
that right now because that's irrelevant
at the moment I've been wearing grow
since like ninth grade I should go to
the flea market and get on outside to
get sue grills and like eight carrot
grills I used to turn I always had
grills oh man oh is that girl's not even
almighty for that just like grills I got
this yellow canary yellow diamond set I
got the colorful set and then I lost my
white set with my rings in my watch
I've ran through like seven or eight
sets they're like seven thousand every
time speaking that man I lost a train
maybe like 10 or 12 rings and I'm
missing that ap a skeleton ap with
baguettes on it the watch was $150
dollars and I had a ring I was eighty
nine thousand dollars five carats and a
whole bunch of other things like 20
grand a little things I don't know where
the [ __ ] they are yes pretty much all
talked out huh and I got a song called
ice fully about Jerry on one night
taking pictures with all mine I was
before I even had you I had no Jerry
back man I was dead broke sleeping on
the couch and never seen a real diamond
in my life
I got some dumb and beads made I didn't
post it though I got a video of it uh
gonna take like a couple hundred cuz I
have six beads on one braid and then
every braid so we just waiting for the
right time to break it out but diamond
have beads I did I did have that made it
so I'm be super dope I can't wait to
wear I was right time because that was
an exclusive right there and this is
nowhere near all my cheese man all my
homies young doing items and I only got
one neck just come to the house
we got the part - you guys come to my
guy crazy video game collection crazy
toy collection got the car collision
just come through and see what the [ __ ]
I spend my money on
[Music]